và pháp tuyên bố sáng sang chín khai lực lượng của sử tửa quay nè, sau khi đạt được một thỏ thận ngừng bắn,
đang sống bước đi mới trong nấu lực định hình thơ chãn nền hậu xung đột, tại cú sai đông ông này.
Thông tin được có bố sâu như thực định tại Paris, bớt sức tham dự của hơn 2 chụm nhà lãnh đạo.
Thủng lên mình tưởng về ông hộ quay nè.
Chúng không có hộ như tổng thống pháp em mà nguy màu khóng,
thu tương ánh kírus tâm hơn và tổng thống Uquay nè, vô lực đia trên lần ski, đã ký tuyên bố bà bên,
mà đường chưa việc chìm khai bình sĩ ăn và pháp trên lãnh thổ Uquay nè.
Khàu thủ tử, giá mờ, sau khi lĩnh bắn có hiệu lực,
khai nước sẽ tiết là các trung tâm quần sử trên khóc Uquay nè,
nhằm hỗ trộn định tình hình, sau lực lượng này sẽ không chứ kết tham dà dàu trên tây nè.
Đáng chuy, tại diện phía Mỹ, ông Steve Khao phần định Mỹ,
cảm kết đón phai trò hậu thuán chưa lực lượng cho ông, sẵn đầu cơ chế giám xanh nửa bắn bằng các công nghệ hiện đại.
Tuy nhiên kế hoặc này cần được quốc hội các nước phía tròn và nhốt cả.